in this video we will browse through
Khan Academy together we will start by
logging into the platform and reviewing
some of the key navigation features
together to get started go to Khan
academy.org and click teachers in the
center of the screen if you have an
existing Khan Academy account select
login if you need to create a Khan
Academy account there are five
registration options using a Google
account clever Facebook your Apple
account or any other email account you
would like to use now let's get started
once you have your account set up you
will start on the teacher dashboard we
are now viewing the teacher dashboard
which is the home page for teachers if
you're seeing a different homepage in
the teacher dashboard you can adjust
your home page to the teacher dashboard
in settings there are a few important
items on this page the courses button
which shows our academic content
organized by subject in course the
search bar which you can use to find
content quickly by name or standard the
Khan Academy logo that will always take
you to your chosen home page and the
navigation button which appears as your
username which can take you to a few
other essential locations including the
learner homepage the teacher dashboard
the parent dashboard and settings if you
want to edit basic information you can
do this from the settings page located
from the drop down of the navigation
button
from the settings page you can edit
basic account information like usernames
and primary language
reset your password
know which email account is linked to
your Khan Academy account
select your home page and much more
it is important to double check that the
teacher function is selected because
only then you will have access to the
teacher dashboard on the teacher
dashboard you will find three very
important tabs the class tab shows all
of your active classes if you select a
class you'll be able to view the roster
Student Activity Mastery progress and
assignments for that class we will
discuss reports more detail in a later
session
if we return to the main teacher
dashboard by selecting the Khan Academy
logo at the top of the page the second
tab is the students tab which you can
view the complete list of students who
are connected to your account this list
contains all of the students currently
associated with your teacher account
regardless of their assigned class
finally from the May teacher dashboard
you can access the resource tab which
brings you to the teacher facing
materials on God Academy and also has a
shortcut to call for educators course we
know that many parents want to connect
their own children to their Khan Academy
account from the navigation button you
can access the parrot dashboard where
parents can add their child and create
accounts for them they can also monitor
their progress and how they're achieving
Mastery in our courses one last
important item to point out where to
find additional help if you need it by
clicking from the navigation button drop
down menu you have access to a full page
of resources about Khan Academy can
Community advice and you can even file a
request or support ticket to our support
team to resolve any technical issues
that may arise we hope this video has
helped you find your way around Khan
Academy
thank you